streets emptied shops closed City bustle
turned to hush
and we watched in our Millions on
screens big and small
one last piece of theater from a woman
who lived life on stage
this wasn't just our biggest ceremonial
moment in history it was a collective
letting go of something that once seemed
infinite
she's always been there she's been there
her whole lives our parents lives our
grandparents lives and we're just we're
never gonna we're never gonna see that
again hit some momentous occasion isn't
it I think the kids needed to know and
understand yeah that's why we're here
the queen visited this cathedral in
Manchester only last year and she came
to visit families in hospital after the
arena bombing in this city royalists and
Republicans tend to agree on one thing
she did her job brilliantly and she
represented one of our finest
Generations
a great Queen who became a symbol of
dignity and resilience an icon even of
cool Britannia
a lot of people miss the queen for her
support her kindness and and you know
she was just an icon you've left a
lovely message in the book haven't you
lit a candle done a prayer
moving in the garden of the queen she's
just been steadfast and constant and I'm
just in Ruffles there
she's just she's just there as a a
wonderful figurehead really
just before midday the country stopped
for two minutes of reflection
Across the Nation the queen had built a
web of personal connections with the
public
helped others in their grief
Gainer lost her brother and sister in
the tragedy that struck the Welsh
village of aberfan is that compelling
feeling of emotion and that overwhelmed
me today to be honest with you to say a
final goodbye to our Queen personally
and and for our community the queen
offering her support come into our van
time and time again it's it's built out
solidarity
where there was division she tried to
unite us she reached out to everyone she
met and picked people at their ease and
very much she'll hear and welcomed us
and welcomed the South to speak together
and come together and she seemed to do
that everywhere she went you could look
at her as someone who was almost like a
family member but also a great head of
state who conducted herself with such
dignity around the world and did the
United Kingdom Pride most of us watched
from home for a country with dark clouds
on the horizon this was a distraction
from reality we could stop and be proud
of our history our country standing in
the world perhaps wrapped up in fear
that now she's gone some of that goes
with her I feel sad because like when
she was Queen she was like a really
caring lady and like she cared for
everyone as one door closes another
opens and you have to hope that the
characteristics of service resilience
stoicism kindness are things that we
take into the next chapter
whatever way she crossed our lives a
visit to a school the opening of a
hospital Her speech during covid she
touched the nation
divided by brexit separated by covid
United in mourning
she was right
we did meet again
Jason Farrell Sky News